ready for an election we're going to go
out there with a very strong message of
how we transform our society to end
inequality and injustice and deal with
the devastating poverty that so many
people face we always said we wanted an
election we do want an election but we
wanted No Deal to be taken off the table
we've now had confirmation from all 28
EU member states that no deal is off the
table so we're gonna go out there with
the biggest campaign this party has ever
mounted totally United totally
determined and I'm absolutely looking
forward to going every part of this
country with my wonderful Shadow Cabinet
team here and all the fantastic labor
activists to give a message of hope
where there isn't one with this
government we shut the stream that
enthusiasm for a moment for an election
are there going to be any further
caveats are you going to say you only
agree to this election of 16 year olds
can vote or if you need further
reassurances in No Deal there'll be a
parliamentary process this afternoon
we're going out there to fight an
election campaign and I can't wait to
get out there on the streets in every
town and village in this country labour
will be there giving a message of real
hope where this government offers
nothing finally what do you say to some
of your own MPs someone we're in the
Shadow Cabinet some of your own MPs had
severe doubts about going for an
election though effectively playing into
Boris Johnson's hands or something to
say and do you think the vast bulk of
them will now get behind an early
general election do you know what the
Labor Party loves a debate but they also
love the end of the debate and this is
the end of the debate and we're going
out there to win okay
[Applause]